what are the pros and cons of YouTube
chapters on the one hand YouTube
chapters are super powerful YouTube
gives us the opportunity to do it and I
think that they are a great way to serve
the viewer they make it easy for people
to see what content is Skip around in it
you'll notice a lot of long form
podcasts like Andrew Schultz flagrant
podcast I'm watching VI ROM Swani was
just on there good episode and like um
he breaks you can hover over and see the
different topics because it's also like
two and a half hours I'm like bro I I'm
not going to watch the whole thing I
want to like maybe skip to a topic I'm
interested in so it's in service to the
viewer chapters help organize the
content they also are giving that's
another optimization checklist to give
reinforced micro longtail
keywords what do I mean it's kind of a
geeky way of saying it you've got the
big topic of the video but but you have
pieces that cover one particular thing
and while I'm not saying that they are
directly related there's a thing on
Google that says key moments like you
type in a Google search there's a
YouTube video there and it says key
moments and those key moments are parts
of the video that are SE searchable and
rankable and now findable and indexable
all on Google ranking so especially with
certain types of videos time codes and
chapters are incredible and again they
serve the viewer better let's talk about
the cons and the debate anti- chapters
is that it's going to hurt your watch
time it's going to make people leave the
video sooner it's going to make people
hover over and maybe skip off the video
or not stay as long and minutes matter
most on YouTube so I think it's more of
a tension to be managed rather than a
black and white answer to just make it's
either this or that I think it depends
on the video it depends on the context
we go a lot of layers deeper in like
ways of how you could structure them
whether you're like more overtly of what
it is or you just like you could
actually say what the tip is or you
could just say tip number one so people
can at least skip through the tips
YouTube if you check the box too
eventually will do auto chapters on
videos it usually doesn't happen unless
the video gets bigger but by default
that box is usually checked so even
YouTube is listening to the video
thinking about the different sections I
have key moments on uh like I think if
we go 2024 camera buying
guide I
think um yeah so I rank on
Google this is Google heard of it um so
this is Google 2024 camera buying guide
and I have a ranked
video on Google's homepage not YouTube I
mean there too but and if you see these
21 key moments if you click this it says
send sensor size video resolution lens
aperture autofocus Auto features size
weight build quality selfie screen and
touch screen record limit on and on and
on image stabilization by the way these
are my time codes and chapters so that's
why I would make the evidence-based
claim that time codes in chapters can be
incredibly powerful for ranking for
supporting like good content for Google
to distribute in a particular way and
bring you crazy like we get millions of
views a year from
Google on our YouTube videos because of
that exact thing happening someone
searching on Google finding a video and
then in doing so they could like be like
okay oh wait a minute clean HDMI and
live
streaming skip right to that point and
then notice this now is a player that is
YouTube and all of the in this video
things are over here uh all the
different chapters are over here so then
there's these links below it we would
get no credit for any of this stuff I
don't think where does this take
you you dog Google it just take it just
lets you search the camera and then take
it from whatever website you want my
final thought is okay sometimes it might
hurt watch time but at the end of the
day and miss me even just sharing my
heart with you like we want to add
massive value to viewers we want you to
like have it be worth your time to be a
part of what we do at think media and we
want your experience with us to be a
positive one and I understand you're
like okay I've seen sea you run ads or
I've seen your stuff or you're tell us
about your course my hope though is just
to build trust that you see how much
value we give and how hard we work and
also that you always understand that
like whether one of our products or
programs or books or something is right
for you cool then join this inside if
it's not cool like hang out on our free
content like like that is super chill
but that what the where I want to air if
I was going to air any on any side it
wouldn't be trying to like optimize
things just to like maximize what the
viewer could get but it would be the
experience they have with our brand so
here's what I mean if I lost a little
bit of watch time but you said the video
is so helpful when I come to think media
it's helpful I learn something it's
powerful it impacts me and so those
those chapters and time codes made it a
better experience for the viewer and
made that touch point with your brand
more memorable and more positive but
that's where I a so I like I prefer to
do them if it supports the content even
if the content suffers because half of
well a lot of YouTube is about the
algorithm and optimization but let's
never forget it's about humans and and
building a brand is what do people think
about when they think about you what has
been their experience overall with the
touch points they've had with you if you
enjoyed this podcast and are ready for
some deep dive YouTube strategy just go
to think masterclass.com to get access
to my 1 hour on demand YouTube strategy
class you'll be looking over my shoulder
as I share my best tips and you can
watch it on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com